You have created all these iconic characters
but you've also had an extraordinary illustrious career.
And I remember going to that premiere
of "Year of the Dog" and I did see a shift
in your performances and your intentions.
Did you ever feel like I have more
than the comedy inside of me
and I'd like to explore that?
Yes.
I did know that and I'm so grateful to Mike White,
'cause I felt like he did give me that opportunity
to write something a little more dramatic
and dark and sad and that character in "Year of the Dog."
And so I do credit Mike with giving me that break, then,
where people were like, oh, she could do drama, you know,
that kind of thing.
Who then you also recently did
"The White Lotus" with.
Yeah, "The White Lotus."
Which is literally one of the most-
(audience applause)
Oh, thank you.
Oh!
Did you love it?
Are you...
Is there...
Does the next season have, are you in it?
I'm not in the next season-
God, no!
No, sorry, this is not good
and this is not the news I wanted, but-
They're shooting in Sicily right now.
Mike's in Sicily.
Jennifer Coolidge is returning,
but then it's an all new and it'll be like, you know,
a whole different, different hotel.
Did you notice how freaked out everyone is
and is responding now to your dramatic acting?
Oh yeah.
I mean, it's like you, whatever niche you wanted
to carve out for yourself back in the day,
like, you're there.
Thank you, Drew.
People see you in both comedy and drama
and there's a reason those two faces are connected
in the arts or whatever you wanna call it.
'Cause maybe one cannot exist without the other.
Is that the point of the comedy and tragedy-
Yes.
Faces?
Yes, that is so true because you have to, yes.
Yes.
And can you turn your trauma into something funny?
Can you, is there the hope of recycling it
into something that does bring joy to everyone else?
I think so, because I feel like that's what I did.
I feel like I poured my feelings and art
into the characters before I was really piecing it together.
It was coming through in the work and you know,
I was very physical.
I did characters who kick
and you know, my dad had a brace on his leg.
It's no accident that I'm doing
these characters that, like...
My dad was limited physically.
He had a limp, but my characters all have an urge
to like break out and kick, kick, kick
or walk fast or they're, you know,
like they have this physical ability
and I made it physical and it was kind of like
my wish for my dad to kick the braces
off of his legs, you know?
That's so powerful.
Yeah, yeah.
There's a story that really speaks to me.
Your dad came to SNL and it was a Mother's Day special.
Yeah.
What was that experience like?
SNL does a sweet thing
where Lorne Michaels does a yearly show
where the cast members get to invite their mothers
and it's so sweet.
You guys have probably seen that, right? Yeah.
And it's become like a big deal,
but I had done the show for six seasons and I was leaving
but I didn't wanna miss that Mother's Day special.
But Lorne was like,
"It's fine, just come back from the Mother's Day special."
And I was like, "But is it okay if I bring my dad?"
Because you know, my mom died.
And he was like, yeah, bring...
Your dad can be your mom.
And Maya Rudolph also lost her mom.
That's right.
And so anyhow, she brought her dad.
So basically my dad loved it.
It was so fun having him go through the ropes
and they had the parents do a song and dance number
and my dad got to go through, you know,
hair and makeup and the wardrobe
and memorize, you know doing a little sketch.
And he was like, "Oh my God, this is exhausting."
He said, "I had no idea what goes into this.
Boy, people don't know."
And so it was just so special having him there.
SNL is like such a big deal.
It's like the biggest, most iconic institution
in the history of television.
But is it true that, by the way,
you got mugged after SNL and you were...
What happened?
I had just auditioned for Saturday Night Live.
They put a bunch of women up at Standup New York
and I had five minutes to do five characters
and I couldn't believe I was being flown
to audition for Lorne Michaels and Chris Farley.
And then I had a wonderful meeting with Lorne
and then I went to my sister's house to celebrate
with her husband in Tribeca.
And then I left and I was in such a good mood,
you know, 'cause everything-
Flying high.
Flying high, and I got mugged in Tribeca.
He came and just grabbed me
and threw me down on the ground and nobody was around
and it was very scary but I was in such a good mood
that I met Lorne.
I was like, nothing's gonna get me down, you know?
And so, he...
He just wanted money and so I gave him my wallet
and then I was like, "Do you want my coat?"
And he was like, "No, that's okay, you can keep your coat."
And I was like, "Oh he's so sweet."
(Drew laughing)
I'm just kidding.
Just kidding.
(audience laughing)
(upbeat music)